dude these people thought that they
could
just join in the mob right that when the
mob started going around with torches
screaming about
bigoted racist whatever some people were
like i know if i hide in the mob
i'll be safe it's not true anymore so
there is that lady alexi mccammond
who do you hear you hear about her she's
uh
a female poc and she was going to be the
editor in chief of teen vogue oh yes i
heard about this but 10 years ago
she tweeted some disparaging things
about asians when she was 17.
well so you're saying she was an adult i
mean
17's not an adult no she was a monster
old enough i suppose
so uh basically these people thought
right right i'm kidding by the way she
was 17.
it's sweets were dumb but she lost her
job and then the company lost a
seven-figure deal
so a lot of people who are thinking i
will go along with what the mob says and
what the mob was saying at the time was
like mocking asians was okay
now they're saying it's not okay and so
all these people are now starting to get
cancelled
themselves so this is the problem with
joining
the uh the woke mob when the rules
change
because there are no real rules they
will cancel you
because you said racist things yeah
jokes whatever
like you said talked about white
supremacy and once that becomes taboo
and they realize how racist it was
they're going to cancel all the people
that were screaming white supremacy
well i'm talking specifically about uh
the the asian stuff right so we were
joking on this show that i'm double
white because i'm part asian
and so i have like you know extra
privilege you know more more than
whatever but now you can say that more
than me more than you ian okay
white male 1 but now now we have this
big thing about stop asian hate
and now all of a sudden it's like
now it's actually against the woke rules
so let me show you this thing that's
going on with this writer
and then we'll just talk about what's
going on with more cancer culture stuff
i guess because why not
ellery smith this is the the big thing
happening right now as as wokeness come
home
comes home to roost you've got
this this writer she says uh was a witch
from hell with references writer at
robot chicken producer and host
but she tweeted in 2013
who knows how old she was she said that
ho she said
she tweeted homemade pod thai and then
she said she did not put her cat into it
though
and so i get the joke i think the
problem with it that joke is that
no one accuses thai people of putting
their cats in their food
that was that was a joke about
stereotyping chinese people and chinese
restaurants in america
so it's just awful writing if if she
should be canceled it's because she's
confusing her tropes
and and her stereotypes just terrible
come on
right it would have been it would have
made more sense like oh i'm making thai
food i'm not gonna
put a seven-year-old boy in it i don't
know
don't people make isn't something people
make fun of like oh you go to thailand
to get a
kid i don't know oh
don't you have to like research what
you're talking about before you just
help
it doesn't help like it didn't work just
now so yeah
yeah you see like could you imagine a
comedian getting up there and just like
saying something that was just
made no sense and no one understood and
it wouldn't hit and you would learn your
lesson and you would adjust and you
don't really get that with twitter even
if you don't get a lot of likes or
retweets like
there's people who just they don't learn
the lesson like oh that wasn't funny or
that wasn't clever
here's the problem with this with this
woman specifically so i normally don't
like to call out the individuals by name
i try to focus on the ideas but
this is important because she tweeted on
uh
just a few days ago but week ago
remember when someone had their snl
offer revoked after using an anti-asian
slur
and so many people thought it was an
overreaction hateful language begets
violence
hateful jokes beget violence they
minimize and they dehumanize and they
allow for the normalization of terror
huh this is the perfect example of this
woman she's a writer at robot
chicken mind you like robot chicken does
offensive comedy okay they're fun
i'm fine robert chicken is fine but uh
it's it's seth green's show he's the
voice of chris on family guy
family guy is like the epitome of racism
you know right i should say
racist jokes and like stereotypical
humor and stuff
it's fine i get it it's family guy
they're jokes it's funny what she's
trying to do
is duck and keep her head down in the
mob
well now they've come for now they've
pointed out her own tweet
she could have just shut up and stayed
uninvolved but she decided to
join the mob to protect herself and it's
only made her more
more vulnerable now here's the here's
the best part she's responded twice
and she keeps making it worse
she says i posted a tasteless racist
tweet when i was 17.
it was disgusting and normalized the
exact kind of violence i meant
luckily i have been willing able to grow
in the past eight years
so i look a lot more like the girl on
the left than i do on the right
she blocked anyone from replying to this
it didn't work
people started coming after her saying
so she admits she's racist
she admits that this is who she is well
much like a person in quicksand
struggling and frantically trying to get
out and then only
sinking quicker actually i don't think
that's true about quicksand it's
probably just like from a movie you
gotta layer on your back if you're in
quicksand
is quicksand even a real thing yeah you
stepped in at once really well like up
to my thigh it was crazy and you
couldn't get out
it gets i tried pulling my leg out my
shoe came off yeah
but i wasn't very deep imagine how many
people like putting their
junk in the quicksand then you're like
that would be awesome then you're laying
down
[Laughter]
get a stick and put it behind you and
then lay back on it if you can my
friends
i would i would i would like to describe
what we're about to show you as
someone setting a fire in their own home
then getting called out for it panicking
and setting another fire in their own
home and
then burning their home down so bad so
this writer for robot chicken
after getting you know attacked for
being racist then saying yes yes
you know she knows she's racist and
getting attacked even more decided the
best thing to do
is to triple down on her admitted racism
by saying
the things i said yeah go the things i
said in 2013
and in instances both before and after
are incredibly racist and yes
violent they contributed to an ongoing
and long-standing culture of danger and
hatred
they are not excusable at any age and i
am deeply sorry
wow talk about i accidentally burned my
house down and now i'm gonna immolate
myself
that'll help yeah don't throw me a bone
i deserve it goodbye world
she she tweeted a stupid joke
in 2013 that was just a dumb joke
then eight years later
someone calls her out so she panics
calls herself
a racist then when she gets called again
she panics
and calls herself a violent racist who
is
unworthy of any of any excuse
okay dude she's a step down from her job
she needs to quit it's the only way
all of these people must quit now i'm
not racist i can't be because i'm part
asian
that's for the two of you i don't know i
don't think i'm racist
well you're white those are the rules i
make them up that's true
oh god and if you deny if you deny
you're racist that proves you're racist
that's actually part of the whole thing
they're pushing i like talking about
race as like scientifically
and like what do they call it race um oh
that's racist yeah
well it's racial but that's different
than racist yes and there's like
racism with a small r and then racism
with the big r where it's like
you might talk about race and that's
racist with the
the adjective but if you're not hating
on it then you're not being like a big r
racist no no no no no matter what you
say at any point for any reason anywhere
ian you're white you're racist period
done
that's the rule so good at this do you
like it some kind of ginger immunity
like am i no i think gingers are like
ultra white
hey whoa okay oh no aren't they isn't
there like a thing where like they're
replacing gingers and movies with poc
what they're like there's like a meme
how much more colorful can you be
like there was a meme about it where
there was like three disney movies or
something where like they had ginger
characters and then they replaced them
with like non-white characters and
people were like they're coming for the
gingers or whatever it makes me say
i think there's something about ginger
that's like they say that you're like
double white or something
super white yeah super white my favorite
kind of tuna when i get sushi
there you go oh yeah it's good it's very
super white it's great
what is it that makes it ginger like
what do you know what the chemical is
i don't know something about not having
a soul mixed yeah that's it yeah it's
just
it's great i think art aren't people
with like red hair more
um responsive to radiation but
or oh yeah you get sunburns like sun is
bad
oh yeah you can but like you can see in
the dark
right and you're crazy so that's how i'm
told yeah
okay people with blue eyes can see
better in the dark than people with
brown eyes really i can see
really good in the dark yeah yeah do you
have blue eyes
yeah and i was in dallas when the all
the black ads happen because i was
performing at a club
out there and i just got really used to
walking around the hotel in the dark i
was like this is great i know where i'm
going that's crazy
no so what can we do to encourage all of
these woke people to quit their jobs
just quit just get out you know they're
just going to do it to themselves
you know they can they can quit faster
you know what i mean they could yeah
they could
hire a person of color to replace them
that would be i think the noble thing to
do
that's weird yeah they never do that
though they really don't yeah
they talk a big game but then when it
comes time to like actually replace them
with someone
who would represent what they claim to
be for
yeah radio silence just crickets can i
say i'm gonna i'm gonna take the uh the
alternate route and say i don't want
them to quit
because it's like do you want to heal
the organ or cut the organ out
and often cutting the organ out is a is
a drastic what if the organ is woke
though
massage the organ you know the liver
it's like gangrenous
[Laughter]
i don't know i think drinking is okay
unless unless you're drinking the wrong
kind of drink like
if you're white and you drink tequila
that's like your liver gets mad like
whoa that's cultural appropriation
that's good to know woke stomach and you
eat like uh veal
it's like yes no i don't know
we we talked about this with harry's do
the woke really care about animal rights
i don't think so god who knows they just
care about like
whatever's in the moment whatever serves
them in the moment
i don't think they care about anything i
mean like yeah this woman who is
accusing herself of being a violent
racist is probably one of the
funniest like cell phones i have ever
seen it's like dude lady just shut up
setting herself up yeah like you didn't
do anything nobody cares you got people
tweeting at you it's like 30 people so
what and she just keeps making it worse
yeah it's always people say oh words are
violence it's like you've never been in
a fight
that words are worse no no no that's
exactly why they think it right
think about it like have you ever been
in a physical fight yes all right so you
understand
what violence is yeah if you've never
been in a fight the worst pain you've
ever felt is when someone called you
like a do-do-head
so here's this this this this ellery
woman you know
and she's probably growing up in some
like affluent
you know new york suburb or whatever
it's a job well i don't know probably
california writing for raw chicken
and so now the worst thing she's ever
experienced
was when you know a girl at her high
school called her fugly
and then all of a sudden she was like
i'm like hyperventilating like this pain
what am i feeling
it was called the name and then she's
like wow
is that how other people feel when
they're insulted
some people yeah so that's why she's
like it's violence to say that
meanwhile if you've ever been punched in
the face you're like i don't care what
you call me just don't punch me in the
face
you know what's really bothering me is
her twisted humor is
basically what got her the job with
robot chicken no doubt like that was
it's
run by the dude from family guy who's
one of the most it's one of the most
racist comedy shows
on the internet i don't i don't i don't
think i i'll say stereotypical humor
like racial their intent isn't to be
like they're not tending to be racist
because that's a harm yeah so make fun
of everybody
and they'll like all the races no not
anymore they announced they wouldn't
make fun of gay people anymore oh
so like they've clearly decided some
things are off limits which is really
interesting
because then what about making fun of
jewish people is okay to the writers of
family guy
you know what i mean like when they were
saying we'll make fun of everybody i'm
like i get it we make fun of everybody
dave chappelle does it joe rogan ricky
your base we
we poke fun at everybody because you
know we want to
show we're all on equal footing we're
all worthy of criticism when family guy
says no
no no not some groups we're like so you
think it's okay
to mock some groups of people not others
now you're getting into creepy territory
because now i'm kind of like what do you
it makes it worse
how do you actually feel because look
you know i point i brought this up
in uh a segment i did earlier today
there's this super like there's there's
this voice actor's name tara strong
i think it's her name and uh she does
like harley quinn from batman she's like
timmy turner
she's also uh she's also done voices for
family guy and she did this one really
racist
asian stereotype making fun of women
female like asian women
and i'm like this is this is a woman who
on twitter screams all day
and night about like trump being bad and
bigotry and all this stuff
meanwhile she's done a ton of really
offensive racist stuff like she was also
on drawn together
super racist stuff and i'm like yo lady
like i don't care if you
voice these characters you wanna make
jokes but then how are you gonna go on
twitter and act like that's wrong when
you literally do it
well that was her job you know it was
okay no but here's the point
it was okay back then making fun of
these people was okay back then
well that's all changing now all right
so let's cancel family guy
let's cancel you know drawn together is
already cancelled but we'll get that off
we'll get it all off the air
uh robot chicken you're gone uh what
what else is getting purged
south park oh man southwestern
the simpsons think about it right so
i'm joking when i say this but they're
probably hoping that's the result
like the woke want to get rid of all
this stuff they want to just like
destroy culture and
and have like this you know revolution
so they're probably super excited the
idea of family guy getting cancelled
because
they've done a bunch of racist jokes i
get them it's stereotypical jokes like
making people the butt of your joke is
not the right it's not my favorite kind
of humor
like it's easy to to tear someone down
and get a laugh
by everyone else but but
and like it's it's more challenging to
make everyone laugh with just some
you know idiosyncrasy you notice about
reality that's my favorite kind of humor
i think so i see why they they don't
want it anymore but
but canceling this just cancelling it
all right seems so
misplaced because like in a comedy club
like you could totally
roast a guy if you're a comic you can
roast anybody at the show and it would
and it would crush and it would be great
and then you leave oh what a great show
called the guy gay in the front row with
a picture everybody would laugh it's
like there's just easy things
and it's kind of just like these
feelings are misplaced now because it's
all in our pocket and people who aren't
seeking out comedy who aren't funny who
have no sense of humor it's like well
now i'm looking at it and i can give my
opinion right away and i feel like i
have the power to destroy this thing or
this person
it's almost like people who you know
don't have a great sense of humor are
being exposed to comedy and they just
like don't know what to do with it
they're weirdo robot people yeah i don't
know if it was ryan long who told us
this
but uh it might have been but you can
tell me what your thoughts are having
done comedy
i think it was ryan but i'm not sure so
i want to put words in his mouth but we
were being told
that when you're doing comedy and you're
ribbing on like some group of people not
like
based on race but like if you're talking
about motorcycle riders there will be
like you know some people in the corner
like oh like make fun of us make fun of
us yeah
people like it that you're you're
kidding yourself you're lying to
yourself if you haven't laughed at a
racial
joke even the most woke people like
right now are in a room so we're
making fun of white people white people
do this it's like
we all laughed at another group and we
wouldn't laugh
if it wasn't kind of true well humans i
was reading about
stereotypes and comedy and they were
saying that humans recognize patterns
but patterns aren't always correct and
one of the things that kind of makes it
funny is recognizing what seems to be a
pattern that's not necessarily correct
right so we have we have this card game
called right or racist
all right so cassandra got it for me for
my birthday and uh
it's an okay game i'm not gonna say it's
the best game in the world i think it's
fun
and uh shout out to the the you know the
people who made the game hit me up
because we showed it before
but it's it's it's it's good in that it
asks you a state a question
or makes a statement and they have to
determine if that statement is true or
if it is a stereotype
and what makes the game funny is when
sometimes the stereotypes are true
and so it asks you a question and it'll
be like
i won't i won't give an actual question
from the game because youtube will ban
me
but some of them are intense yeah some
of them are interesting like dude that
is
race so racist like it's true well
here's the point of the game
it's like it'll say something about
women and then
who's going to be brave enough to assert
that it's true
like because then when it's not true
it's like ah you're racist or whatever
and or i guess stereotypical because
women you're not racist against women
but that's what the
what's funny about it is it'll say like
a study found that x percent of people
from india do this one thing
and then everyone's kind of like i feel
like that's
true but is that racist i know you feel
so racist when you say true
and then but what happens is people are
like i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't
wanna sound racist so
i'm gonna say it's not true and then you
flip it over and it's like it is true
and you're like oh geez
like i have been in a lot of smelly cabs
oh god what am i
saying yeah but there is there is a
question about cab drivers in new york
and their in their
ethnicity national origin and then it
asks you
if it's true i do think
there are some issues with question
formatting because i think you know it
could have been done better but
it's a really good idea for a game that
is really funny when people are forced
to like you lay down a card and the card
says
it's right so everyone gets to see you
saying that stereotype is true
but that's the point i'm making is
what's funny about that game
is what what's funny about the jokes on
family guy right
so there was a uh a joke they made
where like uh i'm allowed to say this
joke by the way some part asian okay
you guys can't say these jokes you're
not allowed that's how it works right
and
it's it's it's alex borstein who is the
voice of lois
and they say something like that's worse
than an asian woman driving or something
or trying to perform a lane change i
don't know what it is but she's driving
and she's like how many uh how much turn
signal do i need to megan to change
eight lanes
zero okay i'll turn now good luck
everybody else and then she just drives
across the highway and everyone crashes
and all the cars are exploding
okay clearly that's not a real thing but
they're making a stereotypical joke
about you know asian women being bad
drivers which i don't know if there's
any data to back that up
but it's a joke that's it i i've never
looked at these jokes like
when i watched i used to i used to be uh
uh i would say
well i'll put it this way i used to be a
fan of a lot more celebrities until i
saw them tweet
yeah right but when i saw the joke from
family guy where
they make fun of asian women they
basically make fun of asian women for
having small tits
and it's tara strong who's doing it and
she's like you know very hardcore tds
i'd never cared arrangement syndrome
sure
well no but like but like you know when
they're on twitter and they're like i'm
so woke and we're all the best most
noble people and i'm like
dude the conservatives aren't the ones
in hollywood making these racist jokes
all day it's you guys
that's the problem is a double standard
the hypocrisy i never had a problem with
jokes about asian people i guess
and then when i say that the whole
people are like well let's go through
and i'm like well i have a problem with
jokes about white people either
it's the hypocrisy you're like racist
jokes are wrong but white people i'm
like nah nah you don't get to do that
the only wrong joke is the joke that no
one laughs at
there you go yeah
and maybe that's it maybe they're just
not funny people yes for sure
for six years i hosted a show at the
stonewall inn
uh and it was a great show and then but
i was noticing like i'm not getting like
a ton of i don't know like fans coming
to my other shows or like i'm not
getting a lot of followers and then as i
grew older my sense of humor developed
you realized it was because you were a
woman and men are bad people
yeah and i was like what is this am i
not i realized
i wasn't a bisexual i just was fun at
parties so um
and then i eventually like got older my
sense of tumor changed i like realized i
was libertarian and then i
like got a show on compound media and
i'm like oh wow these people
love comedy they're showing up to shows
they're following me they
buy our merch it's like oh these people
just like comedy
so i was reading this article about a
woman who became a comic
and then quit because she was like men
didn't laugh at my jokes because they're
bigots
i'm like no no like legit and i'm like
yeah you're just not funny dude you know
that's the weird thing there
did you ever see did you ever see that
thing there was a woman who dressed up
like a man
do you ever see that she she was doing
stand-up and she thought the reason guys
would laugh
people she thought the reason people
didn't laugh at her jokes because she
was a woman so she dressed up like a guy
and then did the set
and nobody laughed and then her
boyfriend was like she left crying
and she's like i don't want to do this
anymore and he's like i'm sorry babe and
it's like
maybe you're just not funny
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time